alors que ces retours sont sociaux à
lviv dans groupe et recherche la
nourriture ensemble autour qui vous
aident les autres rapaces font tourner
les têtes au château de langeais
spectaculaire ces prédateurs obéissent
au doigt et à l'oeil de leurs agresseurs
dont steve pour lui son duel avec le
faucon reste l'expérience la plus
intense le l'oeuvre nous faut qu'on sait
quelque chose d'assez jolie d'assez
impressionnant est quelque chose de
particulier à faire avec l'oiseau aussi
c'est une vraie partie de chasse qui se
fait à l'entrée entre l'homme et
l'oiseau les spectateurs en prennent
plein les yeux ils en apprennent
également pu sur ses impressionnantes
créatures et bien on dit qu'il bouboule
c'est le boubou demande ou ebook à ne
pas confondre avec le nullement de la
chouette hulotte et le choix tu mens à
de la chouette effraie ceux des oiseaux
pastora du public qui se retrouve au
centre de la scène
et c'est quoi vous avez préféré
les royals c'était très impressionnant
avec les oiseaux qui passent vraiment
arabique le spectacle au dc qui est très
surprenant qu'il ait ses joyaux qui vole
au ras du sol y aura des spectateurs
c'est vraiment très impressionnant
si les rapaces foule à ce point les
spectateurs ce n'est pas pour faire beau
l'explication est toute naturelle le
fait qu'ils veulent vraiment au dessus
de la tête des gens ça c'est pas le
fruit d'un dressage c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui font naturellement un
oiseau ça vole toujours d'un point a à
un point b en faisant un arc de cercle
comme ceux ci vers le bas c'est tout
simplement pour s'économiser ce
spectacle immersif est également
l'occasion d'échangés de rencontres veut
pas lâcher un oiseau dans un champ comme
ça puis va prendre de l'altitude ne se
fait pas ça n'existe pas au coeur de ce
domaine royal il fallait bien un aigle
royal lui aussi pour clôturer le
spectacle
[Musique]